americans hit by the worst inflation in
decades could face a summer surge in
prices for bread and baked goods the
overall cost of groceries already up 10
percent in march from a year earlier and
now folks in the bread industry are
warning that prices could rise
another 35 percent in the months ahead
pun not intended due in part to the war
in ukraine scott mcfarland is outside a
grocery store in bethesda maryland
scott good morning
hey tony good morning to you i talked to
a number of leaders in the industry
behind breads and baked goods and they
raised a red flag they said likely by
the middle of summer
bread could be added to the list of
things many americans have more
difficulty affording
in baltimore the h s bakery which makes
then ships breads to grocery stores and
restaurants throughout the east coast
says it's scrambling as ingredients are
increasingly in short supply when people
go to the grocery store they see it cost
more now than it did last year two years
ago and have we hit the ceiling or are
we going higher uh we're going higher
you're going to see another increase in
july
that's going to impact another 35
percent increase on flour and so that's
strictly related to the ukraine russian
war
the war has disrupted production of
wheat barley and cooking oils in a
nation considered the bread basket of
the world
ukraine and russia produce a quarter of
the global wheat supply but war has
halted much of the production
there are still some reserves but
they're dwindling quickly add to that
supply chain disruptions a shortage of
workers partly fueled by the
pandemic and the increased cost of gas
driving up delivery costs
the baking industry calls it a perfect
storm unfortunately those costs have to
get born by consumers and like i said
the most vulnerable in our society are
going to feel that earlier than anybody
else
for mom and pop shops like stella
chorus's bakery in rockville maryland
it's not just flour in short supply what
has gone up in price that you've noticed
almost everything went up right now the
things that went even 30 percent up
ingredients up by 30 percent the milk
the cream chocolate went up to her
bakery has survived 30 years but she
expects to raise prices in august an
anguishing decision she says with only a
slight profit margin with 35 employees
and customers potentially unwilling to
pay in the past my increases were many
years apart
now i have done it
twice
since covet and probably we have to do
it again unfortunately
the industry has been leaning on
washington to free up more federal land
for domestic wheat production and also
to tap into new oil and gas supplies at
this point the u.s makes about six to
seven percent of the world's wheat
supply but in the meantime the industry
is scrambling for replacement
ingredients or for wheats and flowers
made outside of ukraine
tony
i hear you scott